- The most storied division in sports, and it’s ours.
What could go wrong?
- WHOOPS, WE EXTENDED THE WRONG GUY.
- Now it’s ours for the taking. What could go wrong?
Oh no, did I ruin the tank?
- JUST WIN EIGHT GAMES. YOU DON’T KNOW HOW GOOD YOU HAVE IT.
- Got a clear path. What could go wrong?
- [Announcer:] Three-yard gain.
[Announcer:] Three-yard gain.
- Grab it, boys!
- Hey, it’s just me, Josh McCown, left. I think I’m your punter now?
- [TOGETHER:] I SHOULD LOSE TO THE NINERS IN THE WILD CARD.
- I’M OPEN.
- I’M NOT OPEN.
- ZACH, CATCH.
- No. 1 offense in every metric but points. What could go—
- Uh, let’s settle for that.
- JASON, NO.
- Hey, Lincoln Riley, I’ll give you a billion dollars to say yes to me for 10 years.
HEY, DAK, HE SAID HE JUST HAS TO LOSE TO LSU FIRST. HA HA!
- We need help, and I know just the guy.
- SANTA?! KILL HIM WITH BATTERIES!
- FRANK REICH! Thank God!
- [Eli Manning:] DID SOMEBODY SAY SPOILER?!
- GO FOR IT!
- UH, WHAT HE SAID, YES. GO FOR IT!
- Great job, everyone.
- [Aaron Donald:] I can't believe we lost to one of them.
- They can’t all be great rivalries like us, Tom!
- If you want the NFC East to be good again,
Please subscribe below so the NFL will rename the LA RAMS...
TO THE DELAWARE CLAMS.
OH DELAWARE,
WE RAISE OUR CUP
FROM OUR SANDY BEACH CHAIR
WE PROUDLY YELL TO OUR FOES
One two three… CLAM UP!